Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at why
Yankee Doodle called the feather in his cap
macaroni and the origin of the song.
As with a lot of older songs, the tune and
music that we today associate with “Yankee
Doodle” was actually written much earlier
than the 18th century.
The melody may have been heard as early as
the 1500s in Holland, with rather nonsensical
lyrics about the harvest and farmers receiving
their wage in buttermilk.
Over the next two centuries, that particularly
melody bounced around Europe and was re-appropriated
for various other little jingles - like describing
the struggles of English Puritans or used
in nursery rhymes.
(For instance, “Lucy Locket lost her pocket,
Kitty Fisher found it, nothing in it, nothing
in it, but the binding round it”- a rhyme
that may or may not have been written before
the tune started being used for Yankee Doodle).
Another theory is the Hessians were the ones
who originally brought the tune to the colonies
from Germany, where it was being used in a
drinking song.
(Incidentally, the tune for the Star Spangled
Banner was also originally used in a popular
drinking song.)
Much like the origin of the melody, where
the well-known lyrics came from is also not
definitively known.
One popular theory is that similar lyrics
were first used to make fun of Oliver Cromwell,
the 17th century English political and military
leader, for fancying himself a fashionable
person.
The purported lyrics are sometimes said to
have begun “Yankee doodle come to town,
upon on a Kentish pony.”
However, this seems unlikely considering the
word “Yankee” didn’t come along until
years after Cromwell, with the first known
documented instance appearing in 1683- used
by Dutch settlers in New Amsterdam (today’s
New York) to disparage their English colonist
neighbors in Connecticut.
Stemming from the Dutch “Janke” meaning
“Little John,” "Yankee" was definitely
intended as a belittling remark and became
the European way to describe all American
colonists, more or less being the equivalent
of calling someone a "country bumpkin", "redneck,"
or "dumb hick" today.
(Jaywalker is another term that originally
has derogatory connotations- deriving from
the insult "jay," meaning more or less "dumb
hillbilly.")
The first known documented instance of the
tune and the words “Yankee" and "doodle
dandy” being put together in the same song,
it seems, was around the 1750s during the
French and Indian War.
Prior to fighting for their independence against
the British, the colonists were, of course,
subjects of the English.
Therefore, when the French and Brits went
to war over territories in the New World in
1753, the colonists were recruited to join
in on the English side.
Legend has it, whether true or not is anybody's
guess as no known hard, direct documented
evidence has survived supporting this oft-told
story, that a British army surgeon named Dr.
Richard Shuckburg (who is known to have existed)
saw the colonist recruits amble up to join
the regular soldiers.
Compared to the well-assembled and well-manicured
English army, the colonists were a mess.
Wearing “fashions that hadn’t been seen
in England in a hundred years” and holding
every weapon except those “familiar to the
fresh, well-drilled British troops,” Dr.
Shuckburg couldn’t help but laugh... and
write a song.
While not exactly the song we’ve come to
know, the song that supposedly inspired Yankee
Doodle, whether actually written by Dr. Shuckburg
or not, went like this:
Brother Ephraim sold his cow
And bought him a commission
And then he went to Canada
To fight for the nation;
But when Ephraim,
he came home
He proved an arrant coward,
He wouldn’t fight the
Frenchmen there
For fear of being devoured.
Sheep’s head and vinegar
Buttermilk and tansy
Boston Is a Yankee town,
Sing “Hey, doodle dandy!”
The original sheet music for this noted that
the song should be sung "through the nose,
& in the West Country drawl & dialect."
In other words, it was meant to not only be
mocking in lyrics, but tone.
As for "Brother Ephraim," this is thought
to refer to Colonel Ephraim Williams of the
Massachusetts militia, who ultimately was
killed at the Battle of Lake George during
the French and Indian War.
Upon completing the lyrics, purportedly Dr.
Shuckburg gave it over to the Continental
marching band who played “amid shouts of
laughter in the English ranks.”
Whoever really wrote it, by 1768, the Boston
Journal of the Times noted that the British
were playing "that 'Yankee Doodle' song,"
though the Times didn't elaborate on what
the lyrics were to this version.
At this point, the song was constantly being
remixed with slightly different lyrics, tunes
and meanings, as was common for pretty much
all popular songs at the time.
What united many of the earliest versions
of this song was the not-so-subtle mocking
of colonists as nothing more than moronic,
unsophisticated, country yokels.
For instance, after George Washington was
made commander of the rebel armies, some unknown
individual wrote the following lyrics,
Then Congress sent great Washington,
All clothed in power and breeches,
To meet old Britain's warlike sons
And make some rebel speeches
Yet another version included the lines,
Yankee Doodle came to town,
For to buy a firelock, (a musket)
We will tar and feather him,
And so we will John Hancock.
A slightly more familiar version to those
of us today is also one of the earlier known
versions, generally credited to Harvard sophomore
and American Minuteman Edward Bangs:
Father and I went down to camp,
Along with Captain Gooding,
And there we saw the men and boys
As thick as hasty pudding.
Yankee Doodle keep it up,
Yankee Doodle dandy,
Mind the music and the step,
And with the girls be handy
Continuing to turn the lyrics around, with
the colonists variously either taking pride
in the song and/or directly mocking the British,
we have lyrics like
Yankee Doodle is the tune
That we all delight in;
It suits for feasts, it suits for fun,
And just as well for fightin’.
Historians aren’t completely sure when the
verse about sticking "a feather in his hat
and calling it macaroni" came to be.
The oldest known print version of this didn't
appear until all the way in 1842, published
in London in the book The Nursery Rhymes of
England by James Orchard Halliwell, though
this particular lyric is obviously thought
to date back to the American Revolution, partially
due to the term being used here, which dates
it somewhat, and how mocking the use of it
was.
Stepping back a little to a term related to
"macaroni," there’s an interesting side
tale about the evolution of the word “doodle”
to one that’s more used today - “dude.”
According to esteemed etymologists Barry Popik
and Gerald Cohen, “dude” was first used
in the 1880s as a way to describe young New
York City men who had an affinity for being
flamboyantly well-dressed, well-manicured
and overly pretentious - in other words, a
“dandy.”
Using the very words that were used to mock
colonists a hundred years earlier - "doodle
dandy" - people started to call these 19th
century men that as well, as a means to essentially
call them pretentious fools.
Later, this got shortened to "doodles," then
to "doods."
Eventually, the spelling was changed to “dude.”
(And if you're curious, the original female
equivalent was dudine.)
Back to the related term "macaroni"- this
term pertains to the habit of rich 18th century
English men going on so-called “Grand Tours.”
Sort of like the more modern “gap year,”
young adult men who could afford it would
take long trips around Europe, learning about
the culture, art and history of neighboring
countries.
Particularly those from "new money" would
sometimes come back with more refined tastes
- like an appreciation for French art, fancy
exotic clothes and Italian food.
These individuals' often over the top attempts
at trying to appear refined upon their return-
speaking a mix of Latin and English and wearing
foppish attire complete with massive "Macaroni"
wigs and not one, but two pocket watches-
were occasionally mocked for this.
One of the nicknames they were given at this
time was “macaronis.”
The individuals were also considered to be
part of the informal "Macaroni Club" and would
refer to flamboyant fashion and the like as
"very macaroni."
As for the origin of the term itself, it is
presumed to originally derive from the fact
that macaroni was a relatively exotic food
for the British and must have been something
at least some of these individuals raved about
upon their return to England.
The Oxford Magazine described the so-called
Macaroni Club members in 1770 as follows:
“There is indeed a kind of animal, neither
male nor female, a thing of the neuter gender,
lately started up among us.
It is called a macaroni.
It talks without meaning, it smiles without
pleasantry, it eats without appetite, it rides
without exercise, it wenches without passion.”
In other words, when the particular lyrics
"stuck a feather in his cap and called it
macaroni" were added to the Yankee Doodle
song, the author was essentially saying that
colonists were such low class, moronic fools
that they thought by sticking a simple feather
in their hat, they were being extremely refined
and fashionable.
In the end, there were possibly even hundreds
of versions of Yankee Doodle in popular circulation
during the American Revolution, some initially
used by the British to mock their rebellious
subjects.
In turn, the Americans embraced the song,
creating countless versions of their own and
other times simply taking pride in the lyrics
which were supposed to be mocking.
This brings us to October 19, 1781 when General
Cornwallis formally surrendered to American
and French forces at Yorktown, Virginia.
Legend has it that, as a way to mock the defeated
troops, famed French commandeer and hero of
the American Revolution Marquis de Lafayette
ordered the band to play “Yankee Doodle,"
with the victorious soldiers singing along.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please give it a like below and
consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And for those of you of the American persuasion,
Happy 4th of July.